a man accused of killing a teenage girl
during an apparent road rage attack in
Pennsylvania is in custody this morning
police arrested 28 year old David desper
yesterday he is charged with murdering
18 year old Bianca Roberson the recent
high school graduate died after she was
shot in the head on Wednesday DeMarco
Morgan is here with new details about
how the attack unfolded DeMarco good
morning good morning Jeff the Chester
County District Attorney says there is
no indication this is a hate or race
related crime desper didn't have a
serious criminal record and prior court
records reportedly show he drove an
unregistered vehicle and had inspection
violations
Bianca Robertson's parents sat in
silence on Sunday as authorities
announced the arrest of the man that
allegedly killed their daughter Bianca
Roberson 18 years old gunned down
because somebody didn't want to give way
somebody didn't want her to merge into a
lane of traffic david Esper turned
himself in to police early Sunday
morning he was arrested and charged with
first and third degree murder possession
of an instrument of crime and reckless
endangerment Tom Hogan it's the Chester
County District Attorney this appears to
be a savage senseless and brutal act
from one human being to another human
being according to police desperate
Robeson were attempting to merge into a
single lane of a suburban Philadelphia
Highway Wednesday afternoon as they
drove side-by-side jockeying for
position desperate pulled out a gun and
fired at Roberson striking her in the
left side of the head Roberson was
killed instantly her car crashing into a
tree along the highway desperate escape
was captured by surveillance cameras the
act of pulling a gun aiming the gun and
being able to shoot somebody in the head
from one moving vehicle to another is a
calculated act after a three day manhunt
investigators recovered espers of red
pickup truck and at despereaux's home a
40 caliber handgun suspected of being
used in the shooting according to court
documents
Destler had a permit to carry the gun
which he purchased in November 2015
Roberson was apparently on her way back
from
shopping when the incident occurred her
parents said she was preparing for her
first year at Jacksonville University
she was a good girl loved by many never
bothered anybody she was just a sweet
girl source close to desperate family
took CBS News they are devastated his
attorney declined to comment except to
say that desperate voluntarily
surrendered himself to police he's being
held in the Chester County prison
without bail Rena DeMarco thank you